Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
This is the way
This will be my Full Mandalorian Season
3 Episode 2 Video
There were a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references,
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
We're doing a giveaway for Disney
plus memberships to.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and let me know in the comments.
What do you think that Mando is going
to bring back
from the living waters here to prove
that he entered them to the armor?
First guest
would be something to do with the myths
or but careful spoilers for the episode.
If you haven't seen it yet,
we'll start at the beginning.
Work our way through, shot by shot,
Talking about Easter eggs
in WTF moments as we go
along, starting with the episode title
The minds of Mandalore,
which is a reference to them literally
entering the minds of Mandalore.
It was a great episode,
but obviously it feels a lot like a part
one of a two part episode
because they end on a bit of a cliffhanger
like Holy crap, boom slammed the credits.
You probably noticed that
Kylo Ren's helmet wasn't in the intro.
Like they show all the different helmets.
For some reason they took him out.
I don't know why The actual opening scene
opens with the fireworks on Mos
Eisley during a Speeder race.
They claim that it's the Boon
to Eve celebration.
And remember, that's the big reference
to Phantom Menace, the boon to episode
races, the mannequin race in
that were put on by Jabba
like they're having Fast and Furious style
drag races with land speeders
through the streets of Mos Eisley.
Peli motto seems like he's trying to bilk
this Rhodey into more money in exchange
for fixing his land speeder,
which seems like the same model
is Luke Skywalker's land speeder.
Except it's blue
instead of Luke Skywalker's color.
When she references the Middle Rim,
that's this part of the galaxy.
Closer in the series
is largely taking place in the outer
rim during season one and season two.
But we will be going back to Coruscant
later in the Mandalorian season three,
and that's part of the core world.
So we'll just be visiting
different parts of the galaxy
and during the Ahsoka series as well
that will also visit
other parts of the Galaxy and the Skeleton
Crew series, which is also connected
to The Mandalorian and Asoka.
They're starting to use
a lot of these spinoff series to visit
very different parts of the galaxy just
because it is a very big Star Wars galaxy.
So why would you keep going
back to the exact same place every time?
There were people complaining
about that during Book of Boba Fett, like,
why are we spending
so much time on tattooing?
You know, she's got all the same droids
there from earlier episodes previously,
and so she's got the pit droids helping
her, which are also from Phantom Menace.
She's also got the AR five Droid,
which has been there in previous
episodes as well,
which she pawns off on Mando.
We see the grip
that she's running with the Jawas.
I got a quick
bring part of that engine back in.
We'll put it back on.
Then Mando arrives with Grogu, who uses
the force to flip out of the cockpit.
Just like Yoda
in Attack of the Clones into arms.
We also saw Grogu
using the force to be more nimble
like that, jumping around
during the book of Boba Fett
when he was training
with Luke Skywalker at his Jedi Academy.
It's one of the many points in the episode
where they show you some of his newer,
more powerful Jedi abilities.
Even Bo Katan later ask him like,
how powerful you now just to remind you
that he has gotten more powerful
when she mentions the chance.
Q That's another big phantom
menace Easter egg in an Easter egg
for the Millennium Falcon.
Han Solo, but more so, a Phantom
Menace reference when quite gone giant
influence
the outcome of the die that they rolled
to see what would happen to and again
if you won the Padres.
But it's also the same type of dies
that Han Solo has hanging up
in the Millennium Falcon.
Mando asks her about the missing
IG 11 memory circuit.
She says that they don't have them.
She tries to pawn off the R5 unit on him,
which he does wind up using
when she smacks it and causes
a bunch more parts to fall off
and it breaks a little bit more.
That's another reference to a new hope
when the R5 unit in that movie, it's not
it needs to be the same R5 unit
just another random R5 unit,
but it is a reference to that moment.
You also see her DB one droid,
which is the same type
the Cal cast has had during Jedi
Fallen Order.
He also has it in the new game too.
Star Wars Jedi Survivor.
But it's not meant to be
the exact same model.
It's just another type of that model.
There was another Boba Fett reference
to when Peli motto asked
Mando, Did you come to deal with Boba
Fett or the Hunts back,
making it seem like they actually will
introduce the Hunts in a bigger way,
either in future episodes or in future
other series like the Asoka series.
At some point we'll see the Hunts again,
though, and also Boba
Fett has been rumored to guest star
during the Mandalorian Season three.
I do believe he will be in one of
the episodes when they fly away, she says.
May the force be with you.
Just another reference
to growth to the force in general.
People wondering
if mando's also for sensitive too,
because of the way he's building
the darksaber.
We'll see about that.
They haven't said he's
not force sensitive,
but they also haven't alluded to him
being force sensitive yet.
I think because so much of the attention
when it comes to the force in Jedi
training has been on Grogu himself,
like they'll focus on that in the short
term, but maybe long term we will find out
that Mando has some force sensitivity.
You don't actually need to be force
sensitive to wield most light sabers.
Most of them can be activated
by regular people,
but there are some activating mechanisms
on some types of lightsabers
that Jedi build.
They can only be activated using the force
when they fly away.
There's more fireworks
going off in the background,
which is another reference
to the fireworks that go off
during the Booty
pod Race and Phantom Menace.
And at the end of Return of the Jedi,
there are fireworks
on a lot of the different planets
in that ending scene.
They arrive at the planet Mandalore
and he calls it
the homeworld of their people in the way
he says it is almost like he's
including Grogu
as part of their people too.
Like it's our home world, like the Royal.
We there's been a lot of Easter eggs
and references, speculation in the past
that Grogu will eventually become
a mandalorian too.
Like the whole title of the series,
The Mandalorian is a reference to Grogu
you as much as it is to Mando himself,
like Grogu,
who will become the next Mandalorian Jedi.
The songs, The Mandalorian that he talks
about is an old republic reference
before The Mandalorian Jedi Wars
and the Time of Mandalore the Great.
Like a long time ago,
many thousands of years.
There are several references to Mandalore
the Great in the episode two
he mentions the best of our minds,
setting up the title of the episode,
then going down to the actual mines
themselves.
He also reveals that it's his first time
visiting the planet too,
which is a bit of a surprise.
But he explains his backstory too.
He was raised on the Moon Concordia
because that's where his group, the armors
group, the Watch, had been exiled to many,
many years ago.
That's why he hadn't visited the planet
before, because his group had been exiled,
which is another reference
to the warring factions
that Bo Katan talks about later
in the episode
that weaken their people
and let them susceptible
to the Great Purge
in the Empire's revenge against them.
He points out the call of all a planet
they just visited Bo Katan on.
It's meant to be the ancestral home
world of house.
Kryze like her ancestors,
built the castle that she's now ruling in.
She just happens
to be the head of their house right now.
She makes several references
to the rest of her family,
which
we saw some of during the Clone Wars.
So there were a lot of Clone Wars
references in the episode.
When he tells Grogu
who Amanda Lorraine has to understand maps
and know their way around the galaxy
so you'll never be lost.
He's slowly teaching Grogu how to become
a mandalorian, like teaching him
the ways of their people so that Grogu,
who is slowly becoming a mandalorian.
There's so much damage from the Empire's
bombing of Mandalore
that you can actually see it from space
like that green crystalline structure.
You could see that from outer space.
That's why the planet looks
so green like this.
He also explains the Empire's damage
during the Great Purge disrupted
the magnetic field around the planet,
which blocks all transmissions to
and from the planet
which is why Grogu,
who later has to leave the planet
physically to go get help from Bo Katan.
He can't just radio her for help.
You see a little bit of the wreckage
when he arrives,
but they save some of the white shots
for when Bo Katan comes back
with Grogu you are five winds up
going on a scouting mission.
It goes full red shirt
even though there's a Star Trek reference
like the first to get into trouble
on an away mission with the Alawites,
which are the creatures
that used to live much further away
from the Mandalorian settings.
But in the absence
of all the regular people,
they started inhabiting the caves
underneath the wreckage of the city.
As far as I could
tell, the brand new creatures
that weren't in the canon before.
So like brand new for the series, him
pressurizing his helmet is also a way
to show you how he can survive
in the vacuum of space in his armor.
Like they will protect them
like Bo Katan is armor
all mandalorian armor
for at least a small period of time.
It's not as good as an actual spacesuit
or an actual diving suit, for instance,
when they go underwater,
but it will protect them
in environments like that
for at least a little while.
He sees the underground ruins of Sundari.
It's part of this city,
the main capital city of Mandalore,
that we saw all the time
during the Clone Wars.
This is what it looked like.
Like the area that he's looking at
is the area that you see Obi-Wan
traveling through right here.
We get our first big action
scene of the episode with Mando versus
the Alawites using
the Darksaber is the first time
he's used it during season three.
He's still not that great with it.
In is still very heavy in his hands.
He winds up using a vibro
blade knife to stab one of them.
He's used it before in the series.
The reason why the DARKSABER
is still heavy in his hands, as the Armor
explains, is because it's
part of the metaphorical baggage,
like the psychological baggage
that he's carrying with him.
His fears, his doubts
weigh you down metaphorically.
But because we're talking about the force
here, it's weighing him down
physically as well.
It's kind of a Thor's hammer
worthiness, enchantment kind of thing.
Like the more he believes in himself,
the more sure of itself
he is, the more able fighter
he will become when he's wielding it.
The reason later in the episode
why Bo Katan is so good with the Darksaber
is because she knows
exactly what she wants to do
and she's very sure of herself with it.
There are no doubts in her mind when she's
attacking this other creature with it.
So I think part of the idea is that Mando,
when he's wielding it here,
still doubts himself.
He doesn't really think of himself
as a leader,
and that would be part of his arc
during the season,
because during the episode
there are a lot of references
paralleling him and the original mandalore
the original leader of their people,
like he will eventually unite
all of their people using the Darksaber
and Grogu who.
So eventually
he's going to have to believe in himself
that he is capable of being a leader
when he discovers the air is breathable
after all, and Mandalore is encouraged.
It's meant to be this reference
to all the legends about the planet
not being totally true.
Like Bogut,
Han's Mandalorians have all these beliefs
about their customs, their culture,
everything about the planet.
In the armor
has all these different beliefs
and these different customs, and each side
is meant to be partially correct
but partially wrong
in some of their beliefs.
So the air being breathable
was an example of the armor being wrong
about the planet. Mandalore.
She's the one that told Mando
that the planet was curse.
She also believe that redemption for him
was not possible, which he's like,
No, no, no,
I'm going to go and try anyway.
So now we know that the armor isn't
the end all, be all of all things.
Mandalorian When they use their jetpack
and thrusters on Grogu whose pie?
The lower into the civic center
and go to the tunnels
the area they enter here is the same area
that Asoka fought Darth Maul
and during the end of the Clone Wars,
when he won the Darksaber from previously
the creatures they passed,
little reptile ones with wings seem
kind of like they're based on Cyril's,
which are from the canon, but they're like
more hardcore version of reptiles.
I think some of these
are original creations though.
Like they tuned them up for the series.
The area that they go into next
is the Forge area
where the best car was smelted
and turned into weapons and armor.
You see a lot of debris, a lot of pieces
of armor, Mandalorian armor
and some stormtrooper armor fragments
as well, too.
Like it's
meant to be the site of a lot of battles
that were fought because, remember,
the empire raided the area
and bombed it to hell a long time ago
when he digs the Mandalorian helmet
out of the rubble here, The Mandalorian
theme music plays,
but it winds up being a trap
laid by a mandalorian spider droid
that takes him past
a bunch more Mandalorian armor that looks
like this creature here has assembled.
It looks familiar,
but I think this creature is meant
to be an Easter egg for something
like General Grievous during the prequels,
because also using a stun rod,
just like General Grievous meant during
the Clone Wars, a lot of its body
is also very modular too.
Kind of like General Grievous,
like most of his body
had been replaced by cybernetics.
The sounds he makes
also sound a little bit like the sounds
that General Grievous made too, but it's
not meant to be actual general grievous
when he gets put on a spit roast.
They also use this as a bit of a grogu
rescue scene
like can grow to use the force
as he powerful enough to rescue Mando.
Turns out not quite yet.
On Mando's orders, he
then takes off to use Mando's ship to go
get Bo Katan help surprising her.
It was a great moment too.
Like I'm going to go tell this Mando guy
to get out of here.
And also that grogu
pops up in the cockpit.
She seems pleasantly surprised by him,
like she's impressed by his skill.
Like, Oh wow, you're pretty good in
takes them in her mandalorian Starfighter,
which we saw during Mandalorian Season
two back to the Planet To help him,
her face displays
the entire spectrum of emotions
as they enter the atmosphere,
like she's a little bit excited.
But then she sees the wreckage
of the dome city of Sinjar,
which she used to live at.
She used to rule MANDALORE.
From there, it gets kind of wistful.
She keeps talking to Grogu,
who as they travel through the wreckage.
It didn't used to be like this,
referencing the Clone Wars and Star Wars
rebels when it looked amazing.
You remember
she basically lived her entire life here,
which she talks to Mando about,
like when she was a little girl as well,
growing up as part of the royal family.
Unlike Mando,
who had never visited the planet before.
So this is old hat for her, like,
oh, I used to walk around here
all over the place
when she says her family rule at all.
That's a reference to her sister,
Duchess, a teen priest
who I've talked about in previous videos.
I don't know
if we'll ever see her in a flashback.
Hopefully they'll find some references
to her in that future Obi-Wan
Kenobi series or something like that,
or at least through Boka Tanz character.
She also references
her father later in the episode, too,
who we've never actually seen in Star Wars
before.
They never even referenced him, I believe,
on The Clone Wars or Star Wars Rebels.
So I think this episode was the first time
the Star Wars ever referenced Bo Katan
and Satine's father.
It's also a reminder that she ruled
the Mandalorians with the Darksaber,
which she wields later in the episode Back
before the Great Purge,
it was after the events of Star Wars
Rebels,
but during the events of
the original trilogy, when that happened,
there's a whole bunch of Easter eggs and
references for the Clone Wars and Rebels.
When she says she knew quite a few Jedi,
she's referencing pretty much
all the major Jedi characters from the
prequels from The Clone Wars and Rebels
and again Skywalker, Ahsoka,
Ezra Bridger and more importantly,
Obi-Wan Kenobi, Yoda and other members
from the Council and other lesser Jedi.
Like she met Jedi all the time.
The galaxy was lousy with the Jedi
during the Clone Wars
when she says there was a time
they got on quite well together.
That's a reference to the Clone Wars
when they helped them liberate Mandalore
from Darth Maul, the Crimson Dawn
Syndicate in on the bad side of that too.
It's also a reference back
to the Mandalorian Jedi Wars
from thousands of years ago.
Like there was a time when we didn't
get on very well with the Jedi.
A lot of people have also started
thinking about this to the whole idea
that Grogu, who is probably going to be
the next Mandalorian Jedi
and be the union of those two concepts,
like the whole concept
of being a Mandalorian
and the whole concept of the Jedi.
We used to be at war with the Jedi.
Then we fought with them.
And now there is another Mandalorian Jedi,
which is the Grogu
who hasn't become a Jedi yet,
and he hasn't taken the Creed yet.
So technically he's not officially
a Mandalorian yet.
You can let me know in the comments
when you
think that's going to wind up happening,
because Mando and Bo Katan both reenter
the waters,
sort of rechristened themselves
in the traditional style of Mandalorians
taking the creed again,
How long is it going to be before Grogu
who takes the creed?
You also notice the way that Bo Katan
starts talking to Grogu.
She seems like she's being quite
nice to him, unlike her more acrimonious
sounding conversations with Mando.
But maybe that's
just her version of foreplay.
It definitely feels like they're trying
to start some kind of thing
between Mando and Bo Katan.
Like maybe long term
they'll wind up getting together.
They just have this crazy chemistry
between the two of them.
And yes, they did actually get together.
Mando would be able to take his helmet off
when they got it on.
Like Mandalorians
don't get it all with their helmets on.
Maybe they do if they're in battle,
but if they actually became a family,
like they actually got together,
they became a real couple.
He could take his helmet off
in her presence.
That also be another convenient way
for her to rule over Mandalore
without having to kill him
or beat the crap out of him
to take the Darksaber from him.
The other funny thing here too
is you kind of pick up
this motherly energy coming from her
like she's just much more careful
when she's talking to Greg.
I know you're afraid,
but you have to help lead me.
She just seems like she's
being so much nicer to Grogu you take it
a little field trip with space Mom to go
help space, Dad.
They give her a couple of action
scenes in the episode just to show you
how bad, how she is,
what her fighting skills
are like during her first fight
against the Allies.
They show you that she has
most of the same traditional weapons
that Mando has that all mandalorians have.
She also has an energy
shield, kind of like Paz Vizsla, the heavy
infantryman, Jon Favreau's character.
We find that the cybernetic creature
is trying to suck out all Mando's juices.
It probably does that
with the other elements
or any other living creatures
that it can trap just to take its juices
because that's how it survives in Bo Katan
winds up using the Darksaber to kill it.
And notice
how it's not heavy in her hands.
Like she seems like she wields it
with great skill.
That's because,
according to what the Armorer told Mando
about how you wield the Darksaber,
she has no doubt in her mind
about her purpose when she's wielding it.
She feels very confident in herself,
just in general in her mission,
what she's doing right here in her
purpose.
The reason why
Mando has been having so much trouble
quite so heavy on his hands
is because there's
so much doubt in his heart.
She winds up taking out the spider droid
a couple of times like escapes
the first time and makes it
into the larger body of the spider droid.
And she takes out with the darksaber again
easily.
I think this is also a reference to how
Moff Gideon took the darksaber from her.
Like, how did Moff Gideon get it?
He would have had to steal it from her
or win it in combat.
And I don't think that he has the skill
to actually beat her in single combat.
So that means he probably took it from her
with a bunch of stormtroopers.
The whole joke with the POG soup.
Like she says, I can't believe you
of all people have never had this.
It's meant to be a traditional Mandalorian
dish that they consumed
that all Mandalorian children
have consumed for thousands of years.
Like it's a very old dish
in the whole joke with her.
Making fun of him is because
his whole thing is being a hardcore
mandalorian,
following all their customs to the letter.
But yet he's never been to the planet
Mandalore
like their ancestral homeworld, and he's
never had their most traditional dish,
which he
then gives to grogu you to finish off
because one grogu who is always hungry
and because, as Bo Katan says,
all Mandalorian children are raised on it
and Mando is raising young Grogu
you like his son,
but raising him to be taught
a mandalorian.
And earlier in the episode he had this
big conversation with Grogu, teaching him
the Mandalorian ways of navigation, yet
more references to the idea
that Grogu will eventually take the creed
and traditionally become a mandalorian.
They have an argument about the merits
of Mandalorian customs, the creed
itself, with Bo katan
not believing in a lot of the traditions.
It just meant to send it
the big twist with the myths,
or at the end of the episode,
like I don't believe in any of this.
Hooey is like Han Solo making
fun of Obi-Wan Kenobi and Luke Skywalker
believing in the force
in the Jedi's costumes during a new hope,
but then learning that it was all true.
It's all real.
Bo Katan has the same arc in the episode.
Like this is all or nothing.
It doesn't mean anything.
Cut to the end of the episode when
she's like, Holy crap, it was all true.
When they're walking
through the ruins of the lower
part of the city,
she starts talking about the history
of their people, the history of her family
ruling over Mandalore when she says
the Empire wanted to punish them.
That's because Bo Katan,
when she was leading the Mandalorian
during the original trilogy, wouldn't
capitulate to the emperor, serve him
like the Mandalorians wouldn't become part
of his army with the other stormtroopers
and give him their superior weapons
in Beskar technology.
When she talks about how the different
warring factions of mandalorians
weaken their people,
that's another reference to the wars
between their different clans in the clan
that Mando comes from the Armors clan,
the watch
fighting with the regular Mandalorians
and being exiled to the moon of Concordia,
implying that had that not happened,
their people would have been unified
and could have stood against the Empire
and prevented the purge
from happening in the first place.
All this stuff is meant to set up Mando
being the person to unite
all those different warring factions
using the Darksaber and Grogu,
who she tells them about her
upbringing as part of the royal family.
She says she took the creed
and entered the living waters herself
when she was a child,
but she always believed
the rituals were just for show,
didn't actually mean anything.
She talks about her father.
Like I said, it's the first time
in Star Wars that they've ever referenced
satine and her father remembers
the teen was her older sister.
I think we're actually going
to get some Mandalorian flashbacks
to Before the Purge
and maybe even ancient Mandalore as well.
Maybe they'll show us
a younger version of her character
and her father, or maybe the teen.
We'll just see some older flashbacks
to Mandalore before things turn to crap.
You also notice the look on her face
when Mando honors her father,
when she says, Oh,
he died protecting his people,
which is a reference to him dying
before the events of the Clone Wars
because satine
and started ruling the mandalorians
by the events of the Clone Wars.
He died defending Mandalore.
This is the way.
What are you looking at?
He honors her father by saying
this is the way like it is their way
to die in battle for their people
and she's touched by it like it
stops her in her tracks for a second.
Like,
Oh crap, they explain the waters here.
Go back to the time of the very
first mandalore in the cave here
where the waters are
used to be the layer of amethyst.
But until she actually sees
the living myths or beneath the waters,
she doesn't believe any of that.
The whole structure here in the entrance
as well as the inscription on the plaque
here, would have been done
right after the first mandalore like that
very first ruler of their people
united their people in creed,
the creed in the first place.
He is meant to be the person
that started all these traditions
that Mando is trying to obey.
The plaque reads these minds date
back to the age of the first mandalore.
According to ancient folklore,
the Mayans were once amid the sword lair.
Mandalore The great is said to have tamed
the mythical beast.
It is from these legends
that the school signet was adopted
and became the symbol of our planet.
The symbol that you see above
the Armor's armory.
He enters the living quarters and recites
the same creed that you heard the armorer
speaking with that little kid,
taking the creed in episode one.
And as he enters the waters more deeply,
he's pulled underwater by the myth is
or is implied in Bo Katan jumps in
to save him also bathing
in the living waters again like re
christening herself The Mandalorian again.
And as she drags him out
she sees the living
mythosaur blinks at her,
making her believe.
All the legends like this is the beginning
of her arc culminating like,
Oh, wow, everything that they said
about all this stuff, it's all true.
Even though they end on a cliffhanger.
The whole idea
here is that Mando said that he would
bring the armor back evidence
that he had entered the living waters.
So probably early theory he'll either
bring back a piece of the myth, a sword
like a horn or a claw
or a scale or something like that,
or he'll bring back a
Mythosaur Egg.
In early theory, we might get Mando
during the Mandalorian series
riding a mythosaur with Grogu
who in some point
because remember, he's
meant to be a parallel
for the original mandalore
who is supposedly tamed.
This mythosaur that lived here
or one of the myths or is it lived here?
It depends on how long mythosaurs live.
I'm assuming that this mythosaur
is actually the descendant of the one
that was ridden by the ancient Mandalore
just because he lived
many thousands of years ago.
Even Yoda's species like grogu's
race doesn't live nearly that long.
But think about how cool would be easy
Boba Fett riding the rancor
like he has his new pet rancor.
Would it be awesome
for Mando to write a mythosaur
because that's the whole thing
that they reference
back at the beginning of the series.
You are a Mandalorian.
Your ancestors rode the great mythosaur
They specifically referenced
that during season one.
So why not pay that off
by having Mando ride in actual mythosaur
with Grogu
who is also going to become a Mandalorian
That's like the most Mandalorian thing
you could possibly do
Wield the Darksaber, become a Jedi, become
a mandalorian Jedi and right a mythosaur
grogu would be like Peak
Mandalorian, Superior Mandalorian
So let me know in the comments.
What do you think that Mando is going
to bring back to prove evidence
that this all happened?
Like probably something
to do with the mythosaur itself
If you spotted any other Easter eggs
and references
that I didn't talk about during the video,
just write them below in the comments
and I'll do an episode
three trailer video tomorrow.
There's so much to talk about.
My full Episode 3 video will
also post next week after they release it.
Everyone click here already the link.
As soon as I post that and click here
for all my Mandalorian videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe.
And this is the way.